mc oui on a un gros problème en
envahissant les grandes courses vous
avez mis la pagaille dans toute la terre
des lions les autres crocodiles et toi
vous devez partir
pourquoi partir et on les poissons de
somaxon deliciel je crois au contraire
que nous allons rester
enfin à moins que tu veuilles de bottes
quiva g kayhan contre toi il n'a aucune
chance mac où se croient tout permis et
ne respecte personne vestiaire est
sanctionné pas moi qui te le
reprocheraient arrêtés se battre n'est
pas la solution à tous les problèmes
maha et moi je dis que seuls les chefs
lâché faibles ont trop peur pour se
battre non venez on s'en va mais
pourquoi si je me sers du registre à
chaque fois que je suis en colère je
risque de devenir comme ce quart en plus
le rugissement pourrait blesser les
rares poisson qui reste dans le lac
il doit y avoir un autre moyen d'obliger
les crocodiles à s'en aller d'ici c'est
sa carriole prend la fuite parce que le
nouveau chef des crocodiles n'a d'ordre
à recevoir de personne
attendez je crois que j'ai une idée je
ne vois pas en quoi je peux t'aider mais
je me disais que si tu réclamais un
autre machine dano tu réussir est
peut-être à battre mac ou et alors tu
redeviendrait le chef des crocodiles
tuent à assister à notre combat mac ou
s'est montré plus fort que moi il y a
des moments dans la vie où il faut
savoir accepter la défaite
même si tu n'as pas très envie de
l'entendre macua bel et bien gagné c'est
incontestable je sais bien mais ça fait
pas de lui un meilleur chef que toi
c'est juste mais il est jeune il peut
apprendre
alors un conseil petit si tu ne veux pas
être obligé de te battre avec ma cour la
seule chose à faire est sûrement de
laisser tomber
comment ça et c'est tombé tu ne vas
quand même pas l'écouter bien sûr que
non le cycle de la vie dépend
entièrement de nous alors qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
j'en sais encore rien peut-être que mon
père aura une autre idée
coucou les combats continuent bunga
qu'est ce que tu fais encore les
conseils de bons gars ont tellement de
succès qu'on a décidé d'en faire
profiter tout le royaume gars lesage
part en tournée sur la terre des lions
et j'ai un bon conseil pour vous venez
tous avec nous ça pourrait être très
souhaite savourer surtout mal tourné
bunga il faut que tu arrêtes de dire
n'importe quoi
on a déjà assez de travail pour réparer
les dégâts des orages étaient mauvais
conseils complique encore plus les
choses commencent à mes mauvais conseils
pendant nos merapi qui a dit que bong a
été très malin tu vois kayhan tout le
monde adore mais bon ça y est ils ne
seraient pas quoi faire sans moi pas
vrai la raison on n'est pas mal willunga
donne de très bons conseils
tu l'as dis toi même il a donné
d'excellents conseils à la garde du roi
lion quelqu'un parmi vous se souvient
peut-être encore de l'idée du barrage
oui unis d'excellents on adoré tout à
fait une idée géniale à conseils avisés
mais le problème est réglé serbie
maintenant je crois que j'ai un autre
conseil à vous donner
il faut qu'on mettre tous ces animaux en
sécurité gardes du roi lion suivant
bon ça court le fais pas le malin